problem here is that this is a Netflix
series about African queens and it
really is trying to make the point and
you know it's a perfectly valid point
there have been these Black African
queens who've played an important role
in the history of various parts of the
continent
um but Cleopatra is a very bad example
and it's this sort of hijacking of
somebody who's real interest lies in her
Greek cultural heritage and her Greek
ethnicity we're going to talk about race
but as this American University website
pointed out a very good point you can't
really talk about race
um when you're dealing with the first
century BC that sort of language that is
language of the 20th 21st centuries it's
not language that really applies to the
Society of the time of Julius Caesar